one of the things that Biden repeatedly
said
and has been sort of going through the
messaging the the LIE laundering thing
that the system does is that gas prices
are going down so Corrine Jean-Pierre
was cleaning up a little bit after uh
talking about that and we've seen gas
prices go down again because of the the
work that this president has done okay
so she says gas prices go down we could
have played you a longer clip obviously
now we this is what they do this is a
perfect example of how they lie right in
front of your eyes gas prices went down
so RNC research tweeted this out the day
that Joe Biden took office gas
nationally so this is a national average
was 2.39 as you remember a couple months
ago when we were really at the height of
all of this craziness it peaked at about
five dollars a gallon now it's at what
is that roughly that's about 3 30 or so
something like that
yeah something like that I can't quite
see from where I'm looking right now but
the point is it is still above look at
the chart look at the chart it is still
above where it started when he took
office so the idea that he's brought gas
down is absolutely a lie it is above
when he came in by the way I don't think
that everything related to prices of
everything are completely the fault of
the President right or they certainly
shouldn't be in a sane world because he
wouldn't have enough power related to
everything so that if he made a decision
gas stations all over the country would
have to do all sorts of different things
that being said uh in at the height of
this issue when gas was five dollars a
gallon it was basically last summer uh
it was significantly cheaper here and
and significantly more expensive in
California because of extra taxes and
regulations and a whole bunch more
anyway that's just like a very clear
example if you're in a conversation
today and someone brings up to you uh
well did you watch the State of the
Union last night wasn't it great because
gas prices are going down and you can
say to them look I I know you're you're
sensitive you're a leftist facts are
hard to get through to you if you put
your hands up like this a lot they they
generally will not immediately Maul you
and if and but I just want you to know
the gas was actually 239
uh when Biden came in office it's about
a dollar more than that now and it had
peaked it sort of double that so would
you say that that's really bringing gas
down if it's more than when he came in
office and then you'd have to watch
their heads explode and then then they
call you a racist and walk away but you
could try is what I'm saying
[Music]